So i came back.
Graham doesn't write me a letter saying
come back for this festival here in the
september festival which he was organiser
and do things with the kids because he was
a lot of stuff going on with children
born and growing up
and so there was a lot of children activity
in the community in the wider community
for all those sort of alternative
in quotes of the. Scene.
So we had a interconnectedness and
and still doing our social
interacting experimented
and he came up with the idea of why he had
all this pain in his head like got all
these papers nobody want to
paint the faith ards right.
So i said oh i just looked at it
and i had ideas of you know thing
bubbles drifting across the roof and.
You know i think. Oh yeah
well you know right.
You know because i've never done i never
dumb yours before they were just done
canvases but bigger but
i knew i could do it.
That would be done things a large
scale of these things. Anyway.
No one believes that. You know.
Go for it but and also we didn't
know only the only places
that i started off with was the places
that were already. Alternative.
But i did it.
I decided to do it really well and try
and get everybody excited about joining up
the whole to unite the town so i did it
as an exercise to unite the town visually
and i sort of put a lot of energy out there
was a little psychic any good i thought
that was because i i thought in terms of.
Of it's the outreach the global
outreach the whole effort. Behind.
Connecting our. I know this is
this idealist i was mad idea.
And it's and i don't see myself as a mad
ideals i see that we are connected.
Even though people shun
it. Action-reaction.
We affecting the environ we live
on a planet earth which is.
A living thing in the keeps us alive
and we've got to interact with it
and whatever and one
another to keep it alive.
Hopefully it'll get around
to that awareness all over.
And so i just got this.
You know i had this idea of
society in terms of different.
That we drift and we come
together and we drift apart
and yet this is how how things are
and the universe in hard to conceive of
the universe in terms of of imagery of
these orbs that float around because
they have a solar system looks to me
that was my information.
On it so i just thought of that
and that space but so developing
that same idea did in the early stage
and i thought this is a great way to do it
sort of having shaped cameras as i do it
over the fess up. I can really work. The
idea and i want to go an opportunity.
So i know i just i put a lot of
energy and just going from and
and getting these ideas and
i did have quite a idea.
I ended up actually doing a whole street
strip from one in the town right to be
other with that.
Oh well with not just
with the bubbles drifting
and sort of move from the bubbles
and i have papered it off with the bubbles
going off in the flame over the emporium
which doesn't exist now and
then i went on the rainforest
and then onto a quiet meditation
onto the healing center.
So it's a sort of came after.
Just thinking about
and the people letting me do it because
i because they said i looked good.
You know they're going to the concept at
first it was resistance because it was
resistance to.
Some of the people there
but i sort of want to over by saying
what you get into if you be part i do.
Whole thing on the newsagent's was the
hardest one because that's was like the
national party sort of supporters
there around the newsagents and but.
I talked to the woman there so you conceived
of their picture taken of having their
picture. You know. Up there
and do anything glasses
and all everybody you know happy family.
And i had them right up the front.
You know right. You know and i thought all
right. And i thought it was interesting.
They look the quality within you
and how it was the whole place
look pretty shoddy up there
but the kind of paint would
have done it good. Anyway.
So that's our got away whether it's
actually because nobody was really doing
anything up there and there
was nothing much. It was.
You know things at least i'm
giving it a coat of paint
and they showed him the idea
and the idea didn't look terribly
controversial it would be interesting to see.
I was different styles i
just sort of developed.
I just went along and just tidied
up my style. Basically i worked on.
A very simple style which
was hard edge flat colour.
So all even the 3d effect was
created by you know two tone.
Two tone effects.
So it's just flat colour there's no shading
it's just actually just flat colour
but i mixed the colours and i got so worked
off that it was an easy way to design.
So when i gritted up. I knew where
the where i. The areas to paint in.
So i just was it was a matter of painting
an area then you could put in shading
and that i think strong works i was
a big job so i kept it as minimal
and is easy and other people can help the
paint in that sort of see just filling.
Areas of colour from design grid up.
Well was over two year period
of that sort of that that.
That's full of activity of
sort of stream of activity
when i went overseas to look at public
art in other places in the united states
actually.
Yeah well that actually developed after
when i after i finished a mural.
Dollar man you know that's another
sort of character that developed.
Well actually often as a
witness only bubbles because
that whole concert was all
part of a total concept
and they only bubbles actually had a was
sort of appearing disappear was sort of
and it become a ritual it
became a ritual. Performer.
I used it in which a performer got
this as a as a ritual. Leader.
You know ritual centerpiece
or ritual shaman
and where we did so i did a series of
solstice events of the seasons and
and so and they were all related
to that sort of circular
and spatial relationship i
did a. Thing here. Of fire.
Fire ritual i was with
the community and so we.
Concentric circles of 12 balls of
fire things like that but i use
that cos he became i've became
more than just that i had a cape
and i did all this illusionary stuff
so i developed a whole dance theater.
I could do on my own from the injury
a little alone doing workshops
and just doing just dancing with people
and developing my vocabulary of movement
with people like cavalier relating to
community dancing and
interactor in contact and.
All that sort of the you
know this developing.
You know the developing processes
in in. In our sensory.
By billy interaction and movement
and ourselves individually.
So that was part of that
that was sort of a yogic seem like i had
this personal thing which had spots
and that i was a focus on
the take it out anyway.
I could do these events and express
myself in mind you know with that
and just give a as a
springboard to express ideas.
You know. So a good idea. So for me.
It was part of that it that tension
getting attention. And then.
Well dollar man grew out
of after that sort of
that sort of it was very much involved
with healing process as well.
Dance my dance
and the movement i was very much became
part of my as a healer in the community
and
that was this whole process of aquarius was
developing those skills for healing in
actual fact and. So you.
You know sort of community getting
together was healing and.
Well i traveled overseas with and and.
And my first stop was in los angeles at
the world symposium on humanities which
john allen said attend this is
important event and because
that was the thinkers around the world.
Congregating in different areas
around the world and i was the.
There was this the passage in a
scene it was in our in a way
and there was the stadium.
Wimbley stadium in england
it was another thing
and it was in toronto
at trying to university
and they have to move around because it
was government so they were freaking out
towards the end because look like because
it was really challenging the status quo
cassette they also had a. T.v. Link up.
That was going to go on all around.
That's when satellite started
to happen satellite t.v.
and It was booked satellite
to be to link into.
Networks around what about this conference
and cause governments pull the plug on them
all over this whole thing was sabotaged
by governments the actual.
You know i don't think video
and in toronto they try to do
that they moved in
officials moved in to try
and close close down the
university there and the l.a.
One got off with a lot of
difficulty the wembley stadium one.
Just got off i don't know they
had problems there was last
and last minute they got to go meet for
there was problems with management the
government pulled out or satchel was in
and she was creating you know
sort of within down the line.
Anyway the world symposium was really
discussing all these things we're talking
about the military complex and the
problems and the health and healing
and the indigenous
peoples all these things
that relating to today that's
becoming more and more.
You know you now becoming mainstream
and where is mainstream now
that discussion this is the way to go like
to heal the wounds with with the people
that were on this country they were forced
or forced by a military culture that's
all imperialist cultures and all that
and from and the whole culture
that was here with birth related
and connected with the earth
and this awareness was sort
of becoming more among people
that congregate in these spots
around the place and the healing
and so it was like a query a festival.
10 years after but now held in
conference forums with thinkers without
and we had the music that take place and
this ritual but it was held in a sort of.
You know try to be a mainstream event
it was a mainstream event. So that.
Government people
and people the mainstream rather than the
see people out in the field doing it.
And using computers
and technology using all of sort of you
know state of the art sort of technology.
It was a veil. All just
came on the scene so
that was the age of personal computers.
And just just came on the scene
then there was in 89. 79.
Sorry seventy nine was
the. Just before the 80s.
You know the gateway to the 80s
and i was let's look at this era
that we're just going through
with yet now and it was just
and also the nuclear power station
in three mile island just blew up.
Well nearly blew up you
know so there was that
and so there was a big movement towards
having this this these forums.
And so there was a whole people simple
then i was there was a lot of learning.
I made the connection with pallas alarie.
Aka sante
and that's whole the whole idea of
permaculture city which he had going then
called an archaeology process so
moved on from frank lloyd wright.
That's another story and that and.
And i then took part then the whole
nuclear issue became i became aware helen
caldicott was there was there and there was
ralph nader and i spoke to ralph nader.
After one of his talks
and he said well the best way you can
get in touch with people is one to one.
Talk about all these little
trying to x and this and
that this is great if there's one
thing one so that's stuck in my mind
and he's raised stuck and
i he does talk and i.
I picked up the tapes from
what was taking place there.
And in the nuclear issue was
when i got back to australia the
nuke issue was was a big issue
and the aboriginal issue.
With a lot of things happen america won't
go on because the whole story in itself
my journey through the whole public art
and was involved with the. With no nukes.
No nukes event in. Three
mile. Not that in ny.
When new york was a whole
month of alternative energy.
It was quite progressive
like there was tours
and electric buses going
around to alternative things
that are happening in new york city and
that was going on then there
was a whole plan of action
when you with the no nukes
concerts on took place on the.
Which was recorded with all these stars
and it was a whole movement from hollywood
and around the country coming to new
york or sort of on the road journey
and i came to new york with this big
month of event. Months of events and.
That all technological fair of
alternatives to. Direct action.
And then there was you know
stopping wall street and.
And getting in touch with all the new
call it quits the weapon groups and all
that but the whole thing was.
The whole link of the nuclear power
anything with the weapons in this tree.
And how it's it's really dangerous.
You know really bad news
but alone it's the cold war is
creating real real problems in.
It just the whole military industry
and this was going to hold madness
that we need peace and not
war and nuchal ip nuclear.
The nuclear stuff was showing its evil
rearing its nuclear head with the three mile
island accident and a lot of
people on the road anyway.
So i decided to be part of that to help
with it. I didn't have a dollar man there.
That was sort of happening
later on because at
that stage i was just there helping
and just giving out leaflets and.
I was there as a visitor. And
when i came back to australia.
There was a new cumber and so
i was with a sort of help.
Help that it did a flag for big
aboriginal flag that was up.
There was 1980. At st.
Paul's cathedral so i was there
and i had the workshops developed
i still was working on dance.
I was involved dance all the time.
Dance and murals that whole concert
with the bubble still developing.
With planet of us now and into the public.
I think all are still developing and.
So the. So then after
nukem after that one.
You know was direct action and street
event and also observe street theater.
In america and. And i had in my
mind implicit certain images.
So i didn't know where i was going
there because i still was in to dance
and murals
and healing as a really important thing to
like the way i was going was really good
like that positive
but it sort of started to dawn on me with
our oversight of my abs observational
direct action on wall street
that wall street action.
Sort of 50 years since wall street collapsed
i tried to create the same scenario.
I have. Over the.
Over the nuclear to stop whole street to
stop wall street over the whole newcome
industry and do no nukes and i came back.
Cut the story short i came back
and i was i heard after newcombe
i heard about the middle head
and it was a healing festival and
that and the solstice and that.
I was into rituals and. And
healing and so forth but.
When i got got there i heard the story
that the bulldozers were coming in any
me any pick up a clock to clear this
beautiful beach you know
and people meditating
and doing you know going to have a strong
with a great importance the aboriginal
people middle head and
terrain you just happened.
The year before and i was
connected with the terrain you
and you from corresponds i was at no
nukes concerts while touraine you was
happening. So there was following. Saran
yeah. So it keyed into that sort of.
Movement.
Even though i haven't been arrested
before this was my first the rest of the
situation i found like a little head and.
So there i really started.
I don't know what sort of like i was i was
it really got to me i just start seeing
machineries as monsters.
It actually got to me like a naughty
feel for people and the authorities
and how we isolated the media
slanting that was going on.
You know making us with
a bunch of terrorists.
All we had was that the whole people
occupying an area and asking questions
that hey you know hold it
and you know this is not sort of devastate
this beautiful area this is very rare
and course we were put in a position where
we were pitted against these machines.
And the operators of the machines
and the machine people could
so i could see the sea
and i was into a long stint of meditation.
After they waylaid the first sortie
while there was the first sortie
and then i got arrested in
that sortie of the forest because i saw
100 trees grow we have this regard very
sensitive to the trees and because
singing to me. I mean i had this.
I was something something was going on.
You know i don't know what it was
but i could hear the voices.
And things i was sort of
spun out i could see the.
Because i did a lot of
meditation and yoga.
That's developing that time
and all of a sudden this sort of other
thing was coming to me it is no answer.
I mean i'm not into sort of saying
that god spoke to me but i was
or something like that and then sort
of like all the sudden i just hearing
that crying out there is something
you know and and the birds and
and dead birds on the ground and the whole
nature was in disarray i could see it.
I was sitting among it. And we were in there
and a lot of maggi was a lot of meat.
We with the people there
and i mean there was a certain feeling a
certain things were happening manifesting
and you just felt there was a certain
strength even though wolf you were very
strong and very powerful people
in a burning burning coming up
and you know we had the indigenous
people and that was very special because
that was becoming aware of
the indigenous culture and
and how you know listen to them
and in the come from the primal roots they
actually indigenous people have primal
roots go right back. Of.
Before we became inventors of
and trying to think we are god
and change the world
that we actually part of nature they who
are living with nature back in those days
and civilization crippen's i was
aware of that sort of connection and
and aboriginal people of this
aboriginal awareness from
that nuba absence of was there and then
it was when your record's coming up.
And again. Graeme dallas
and sort of flew in said graham doesn't
actually have a great influence.
I mean a lot of people have a lot of
flack on him but actually he's my hero.
One of my here. Because the actual fact
he sort of triggered me off another way.
I mean he also you know sort of triggered
off ego type things as well like exhort
where did things it was a good
critic i mean he's a critic.
You know writes and critics
and he stirs up stuff
but he is is good because he stirs up this
stuff to really bring out. Real issues.
You know question of you know and for
change. So members on the beach.
I was wondering so what
are you going to do.
Benny that basically does all this is
happening because i wasn't prepared for us.
I was still into this thing you know so
doing yoga meditation doing circles.
You know all these things
or sort of appeasing.
People sort of you know sort of crawling.
To say hey you know it is that this
is the way you go and i think not so.
Seeing that we actually
are dealing with it.
Evil situation a situation of people
don't want to change fear. Inch.
Well you know they're true
intransient and that's hip and.
And i just go through it. Then you know
they won't listen to anything else.
They won't listen to that side of it.
So i want to shock them you know i mean we
needed to do something dramatic you know
i just have to sit
and meditate i mean i wanted to i
didn't like to to really create
that sort of i don't know what to do.
At that so
and then if it was set up as a recycling
theatre type idea to do actions.
Input of course and i
just came out of jail
and we weren't allowed to
get back into the area
and so we were actually we
would have been caught.
We would have been in trouble so was
all these sort of come together
and came up with a concept we put
on masks and we did these action
but we had enough they would know who we
work with if they were being identified we
would have been arrested so so
so we made masks and things
but so i started i created a recycling camp
after grammar so what are you going to
do so i decide to do that and learn
about it was talking about doing this.
And idea of doing a crucifix.
You know like this sort of a crucifix idea
of because we only had one way of going
to the beach. You know all the rest of
us forest and all guarded by police.
All the way down so we sort of created
that into that the police being
that the sense durians and
we set up these crises
and one was was different was we had three
crises one one was for a woman was a
woman on it and we had a.
And i was a hippie and i was aboriginal
so we had a sort of as a chris a fight
and it was all built out of this out
these cruises we made out of the trees
that were way late and we did
this one of the action and i mean
when we sank down by the water.
It was a whole production and was filmed
by by by an a b c excite a b c guy.
Which is name and i think it's in his name
but he filmed it because
no media would turn up.
He was a person there with a
super 8 and he'd just filmed it.
Remember that action was really
significant. So i set up that camp to help.
And it's just that this project that
they all came together all at once.
I guess was this group mind.
There was an aboriginal embassy there to
the embassy from canberra move to middle
head for the actual that they were
kicked off or something happened
and they moved to middle here
and i didn't think they were kicked off
they just sort of moved to middle head
decided i don't know what happened
yet but i moved a little head.
So there.
Well enough meditation i had these goals
and you know these things came up in
and sort of and degree days and
and sort of like is about greed
and i saw these monsters and i sort of
agreed oser and company was about greed
and
that sort of just hit onto me this idea of
the doe's earn the green i thought i was
a concept i put together for greedo then
companies so out of recycled plastic and.
And. And cardboard make greed doesn't
come and so was the first stage
that was that's the first stage of
that development and then you know
that fell apart and i developed a bit
with paper mâché in a grew and then.
As i went down around actions i developed
that costume as part of doing banners
and flags
and all the rest of it for actions i
developed my own theatre piece my own.
Expression which would be a sort of the
shtick ghost will appear because we're
doing ghost actions.
With these sort of dark at night
would come in and sort of move in
and do these sort of you know
do actions with our cost
and so sort of an idea
and it was anger involved with it
at the time and now it's changed.
No not anger
but actually sort of developed as i
developed it became sort of i mean there's
anger but now it's sort of like
hey can't you see what it's about
and we want to just sort of just get into
changing you know for that sort of thing.
It's all these are most mixed reactions
go on. But that's not sort of aim to.
To justice. Plan but it's actually
sort of to help with enlightenment
and lightening people for changes
and so if i take them around
and it's sort of the media pick up on it
really well you know i'm going to god i'm
really good. I'm a good. Good
produce projecting my body.
With the images and the whole
you know just i just practice.
Rehearse it every time i do
it is another rehearsal.
In the movement. Yeah i know
that i've developed a develop
that i was sort of deliberate
development of an icon without.
Spelling it out just doing it you know
just so i just throw myself into the.
Into you know help create the theatre
and then it's just a little piece
myself like everything set up and it's.
Demy number and and when i get arrested.
I use
that as part of the early hours of play with
the with everything around me to create.
Just so that when when
they when the shutter goes
that sort of you get a as if
you've got these totally images.
And they can use it and just hope the media
will use it and some do and some don't.
It all depends and some.
Distorted it i mean i've seen i've
seen the whole sort of monkey business
that goes on with the media different media
as you know some distorted where they
totally were totally ignored it
or they turned it into something totally i
did you know it would have to interpret
it totally dark rather than give the
full story. You know what it really is.
But then others said i was using it
but every time they put it in there
it was a plus like media's a plus.
Even if they give you bad ass
to me bad media is still media.
I mean it actually raising people
are being raised about the issue.
I mean even though they can call us what
they we like they like you know these
and dirty unkempt paul.
And dog bludging whatever it's still
the issue was about a forest.
The paring toxic waste
going into the system.
You know these things
and if they really people want to really
want to what are these people on about
they'll know they come up and people
are come to the actions as people
that come up they find out even
the journalists that turn up.
They get they get a mouth. They get
an earful of what we're there.
If they rejected that you know on the
cutting on the cutting board you know
when in the cutting wherever it is
you know in the editing stages.
It's you know on the policy wherever
there is they still got the information
that made its way into
goes into the politician.
So they all they let they
get it if they listen
or not getting the information has
been a really good tool to me
that direct action always. Is
still good because it does it.
It is sort of you grab them when
they say oh well you know we just.
I will listen to them but with you
know business as usual sort of thing.
So they're just sort of
hold them to ransom.
You know non-violent direct so the other
thing is doing non-violent direct action
and
that whole development of non-violent direct
action of doing things to make people
aware.
Without you know with without
going to war over it you know
or so it was it was an exercise in
that itself like the theatrical
of the direct action of theater.
And the repeating yourself
in arrestable situations.
The fear base. Well oh yeah.
I observe i observe people's
expressions through the visor.
I mean every time i get
up and i listen to people
and the feedback is a lot of people within
the movement say it's great because it
got me involved a lot of people sort of
helped a lot of people to be. In our.
Since also plays on the guilt of people
like you say you know they were consumed
just go along just forget
about it you know and.
You know sort of you know
suffering up the earth.
You know your lifestyle is just let it
happen if you're not on the fence you know
you're part of the you're part of the
problem if you do nothing to you.
Just letting it happen. So it's
played on the guilt as well. And was.
Well i sort of i develop those
slogans after it sort of developed
that sort of other development
sort of greed those of us
that sort of like you know you know
this is what we're looking at here.
This is awful for money.
I mean there's no other reason why they
want to knock down it's just for money for
the retail
and you know was work
consumed be silent guy
that came off off of.
A graffiti in adelaide and i picked up
so i added that on to on to the toga.
And then i rely on yapper see
that sort of piece that in when
when i was in queensland sort of all happened
in stages over time left period sort
of over a couple of years from 90 80 to
90 90 to the sort of fully established
character.
And then it's costing the earth
and that sort of grew out of.
The franklin. Put that on. Before that and
i was actually before the friend i was.